the diver screams A Silent Scream as the
giant Squid's beak digs into his skin
its many grasping tentacles grabbing him
and holding him in place nearby his
fellow divers are driven half mad with
Terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the Merc
and strange Russian voices speaking in
their heads nobody can help them they're
down too deep too consumed by the
darkness and the pressure of the sea
they're now at the mercy of whatever is
inside the submarine beginning in the
1940s with the dawn of nuclear weapons
the American government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage What
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the sub Soviet Union crossed into
the cold reaches of outer space
deploying the satellite Sputnik the
United States responded with the
founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962. as United States
citizens feared they were teetering on
the brink of nuclear war in July of 1968
the Soviet Union the United Kingdom and
the United States came together to sign
the treaty on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as
scp-741
scp-741 is the underwater wreckage of a
Soviet submarine that sank in March of
1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the U.S
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible Euclid or
ketterclass anomaly in the rack at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hull was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seemed to have left something
behind whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices an incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described an incident report
1741-a divers a 26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surround founding the wreckage
as the group of divers approached the
submarine they could feel the shift in
the water around them the oppressive
feeling of abnormally increasing
pressure bearing down and threatening to
crush them if their specialized diving
equipment were to fail they knew that
that would be it and the command would
have to come and fish their corpses out
of the water or even worse they would
vanish entirely meeting the same
mysterious fate as the crew of that
doomed submarine but they couldn't
fixate on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the site of movement from within the
wreckage spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
proceed to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when the team checked the radiation
levels in the area they remained stable
whatever the source of the glow was it
wasn't radioactive at this point his
Neutron counter began to register
something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
can you hear me the voice was muffled
and though could be heard over their
communication channels it emanated from
somewhere in the wreckage deep deep
underwater as a29 watched a glowing
shape emerged from the darkness it was
only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted the operation
2 and began to panic some checked their
nitrogen levels believing it to be some
sort of nitrogen Narcosis While others
pointed out that they couldn't all be
suffering from nitrogen Narcosis at the
same time the unknown voice continued
speaking saying if me it is getting hard
to breathe the divers debated what to do
next questioning whether what they were
seeing was even real when all at once
the humanoid figure vanished from sight
the divers attempted to shake off the
startling encounter and they resumed
their duties the investigation
proceeding as normal after a few moments
of uneventful work another Interruption
presented itself in the form of a five
meter long squid swimming around the
wreckage its presence startled the
divers at first particularly those
closest to the animal but the others
encouraged them to ignore it citing the
fact that there are no records of these
squid attacking humans so they did
continuing their work as the squids
circled them with apparent curiosity a27
Spa added an unusual shell below the
wreckage notably large and difficult to
identify and control requested that they
bring it up to the surface for further
inspection by a marine biologist the
diver began attaching Hall cables to the
Shell as the squid crept closer and
closer all of a sudden a26 screamed and
there was a sudden Bloom of blood in the
water the squid despite it being
uncharacteristic behavior for its
species attacked the diver biting him
savagely prompted by cries for help from
the diving team control began to reel
a26 back towards the surface proceeding
slowly to give him decompression time
and the squid took advantage of the slow
Retreat it chased after the diver
grabbing hold of him and biting down
again tearing away at him as it gripped
him in its tentacles still control
continued reeling him in hoping to free
him from the Squid's grasp as they
yanked him to the surface the other
divers were ordered to get themselves
out of there as fast as possible in
order they gladly obeyed as they swam
and back to the surface a30 saw
something else moving in the depths he
couldn't make out what it was but the
sight of it gave him a sick feeling of
dread deep in the pit of his stomach the
four divers were recovered alive along
with the shell examination of the shell
indicated that it resembled that of the
extinct orthoconic nautiloids but it was
not fossilized it was taken for further
study given the possible implication of
extinct species anomalously manifesting
in the vicinity of scp-714 diver 826
lost a limb and was exposed to an
unknown Venom via bites from the
attacking squid his camera was destroyed
in the process as squid are not known to
attack humans unprovoked this Behavior
has been attributed to the influence of
scp-741 though the exact link between
the two is yet to be determined an
anomalous pressure gradient surrounds
the wreck with a radius of approximately
250 meters starting around the center of
the submarine the pressure in this area
is much greater than it should
given the depth of the waters there this
unusually high pressure makes sonar
analysis extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and U.S
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basisti was patrolling the area
around scp-741 when its sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching scp-741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basisti attempted to reach the contact
via sonobui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone they became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an underseen missile launch
and vasisti responded with the utmost
urgency the ship broke away from its
original area and fired a type 53
torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the basisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 meters
and a velocity of 0.92 Mach the missiles
did not emit any detectable radar nor
did they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the basisti both of the
missiles were engaged by basisti's 3kn5
kinsol surface-to-air missiles and
cashdan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 meters and 210 meters
from Impact respectively after the
missiles were neutralized the Hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in
evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward scp-741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident
1741-c the sonar recordings from the
scps specisti during incident
1741-c were taken for further analysis
by the research team the in-depth review
revealed anomalous acoustic signatures
that did not match up with any known
forms of propulsion including
magnetohydrodynamic drive currently the
nature of the unidentified attacker
remains a mystery and it has not been
attributed to any particular government
or organization following the incident
involving the scps basisti an American
intelligence agent reached out to the
foundation offering further insight into
the secretive government programs
looking into
scp-741 in agreed to sit for an
interview with a foundation researcher
assigned to the project on the condition
that his identity remained protected the
SCP researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
the foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his informant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crewmen We buried
Just Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward while the
director and didn't it's something I
can't fully explain this particular
statement puzzled the foundation
researcher raising questions he hadn't
anticipated only uniforms did this mean
that the sub had been unmanned the
informant replied no no not unmanned
there were no bodies but personal
effects were everywhere along with
uniforms there was some blood human
before you ask on one of the Torpedoes
in a bit of skin where somebody probably
crushed his hand load in the thing just
no bodies left when I first looked into
all this I had no clue what the hell had
gone on down there but I started putting
things together the foundation agent
began to speculate based on the mounting
evidence could it have been a Soviet
weapons program a deadly biological
agent of some kind no no it wasn't that
I thought maybe it could have been so I
dialed up some of my contacts at vile
preparent a spies wind up owning each
other favors after a while and they
denied it vehemently not your usual
cover-up baloney either they clearly
stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted no
part of it sounded like he was gonna
puke when I mentioned redacted doctor do
you have any idea what it takes to make
a bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the U.S of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loaning you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that scp-741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships as CPS basisti and
krasno yarsk has been selected for this
purpose if any unauthorized activity
occurs in the area surrounding scp-741
nuclear and conventional missiles may be
deployed any movement of scp-741 is
grounds for an immediate Nuclear Strike
whatever Secrets as CP 741 holds
whatever it was transporting that was
even more of an uncontrollable threat
than nuclear warfare they're better left
alone down there at the bottom of the
sea now go check out
scp-2316 the bodies in the water and
scp-054 water nymph for more